foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me you
go oh my God
great outfit
hey
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
yeah
uh well everyone welcome to the the
Tesla Design Studio where we've helped
many product buildings before I hope you
guys all have a really great time
tonight uh I think I've never seen so
many cameras in my entire life this is
this is hammers everywhere
um so we're going to start off by just
talking about about how did we get here
you know what what are the things that
have led to this day uh what are the
cars like
how did Tesla start out how did we
you know where were we 10 11 years ago
what has happened over that intervening
time
you know because it occurred to me that
a lot of people
they only heard about Tesla maybe a year
or two ago
and
you know electric cars that kind of like
taken for granted but
there was a time when electric cars
seemed very stupid
and it wasn't that long ago and the
the idea of creating a car company was
stupid of course and then making an
electric car company was like stupidity
squared
and um
so let's let's take a look at the first
car we ever made the Tesla Roadster
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
it's a bit small
um
it's great it's great
um so so the crazy thing is uh if you if
you go back 11 years today Tesla had
made one car that car
that's serial number one
of of Tesla
so
that's that's my car actually
um so
yeah
[Applause]
so on February 2008 uh we had literally
only made one car that car
um and didn't really work very well I
have to say
it broke down a lot
and it took us another three months just
to make the second car
and now uh We've made about 550 000 cars
[Applause]
and after the the Roadster uh
essentially what happened with the
groceries where he said okay we don't
want to make a car we want to really
break the mold about you know how do
people think about electric cars to
think about electric cars as being slow
and ugly and and poor performance so we
wanted to have a sports car you know a
car that is fast looks good uh sexy
that's right haha oh you took the words
out of my mouth
so exactly
sexier
that's right
so so the the Roadster we weren't the
reason we did a sports cars we wanted to
create a car that would break the mold
for electric vehicles and that that
would be yeah sexy and and fast and long
range and that's that's why we did the
Roadster
um and uh you know people people said
well you won't be able to make the you
won't be able to make a call with those
specifications and if you do nobody will
buy it so we had to prove those two
things wrong and then after we made the
Roadster they said okay sure you can
make some toy sports car but you can't
make a a sedan you can't there's no way
you could compete with the uh the the
the luxury sedans of that are gasoline
because they're the best and there's no
way you could make an electric car
that's like that so we did
yeah
Model S
[Applause]
exactly so noisy we're all the fumes
where's the exhaust pipe where do you
put the gasoline
so we actually started designing that
car in the rocket Factory so we didn't
have a design studio
um we took a little corner of the rocket
Factory and and Friends joined and we
just uh
with a tiny crew in a corner of the
rocket Factory we designed that car
um
and uh I think this that car is really
important because it was competing
against the best of the gasoline cars
so if you competing against if you can
make an electric car that can that can
beat the best the gasoline cars that's
just a it's a very powerful statement
um to prove that that you can go
Electric
so then
working on the from the Model S
which by the way
um
in terms of where the name comes from
actually I like calling things what they
are so Roadster is called Roadster
because it's a roadster there is no
there is no good word for sedan
so we couldn't call it the sedan it
wouldn't work or Saloon there's just
like literally no word so the model S
stands for Sudan
and
this is how out of touch I was I
actually didn't realize at the time that
model S also means models
and and then I had like a one point a
license plate that said
model S2 because it was like the second
production Model S and it was like and
as I was walking away from my car I said
wow what a jerk he's license plate says
models too
yeah like okay better not have that
license plate
so um but then going from the from the
model S we said okay we want to make the
the best SUV in the world
um we want to do something it kind of
carried away actually with the model X
um it's like let's let's have
practically every every technology and
whisping thing we could possibly think
of
um and uh the model X is like as a car
it's like a Faberge Egg meets a
spaceship it's like
um it was insanely difficult
um
but it but it is it is an amazing
vehicle let's bring it out
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
you can see a certain position forming
Maybe
so the the model X
um
like yeah like I said it really feels
like a Babbage egg spaceship
um
and uh
it's it's X for crossover SUV
um but then after we had the model S and
Model X
I thought it'd be pretty funny if if we
had the model e
um
uh and yeah and and then but then like
Ford threatened to sue us uh
[Laughter]
Ford killed sex
[Laughter]
but I said what if we call it the model
3 because that's completely different
for me they said that's fine
[Laughter]
so if the the model three let's bring up
model three
[Applause]
that's right
that's right exactly
exactly smart summon with a person
[Laughter]
so we made the original Roadster
the model S the model X the model 3
and then we also uh
then made the new new generation
Roadster
which will bring in
sweet
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so yeah here we have the
original Roadster the new Roadster
[Music]
and then hey how's it going
and then the semi
[Music]
[Applause]
the actually the Tesla semi drove here
non-stop all the way from the Bay Area
so that Tesla semi a 500 mile range
electric uh semi I learned to actually
uh only after naming the thing that semi
has two or two meanings
um
it's semi-sexy
[Laughter]
so um
yeah so we're really excited about
bringing those products to Market
and uh
so that's sort of talking about our
products but then the the factories are
as much are are as much as the product
if not more uh than than the uh the
vehicles themselves in fact I I really
think like the the difficulty and value
of manufacturing is underappreciated
it's insanely it's like relatively easy
to make a prototype and extremely
difficult to mass manufacture that
prototype or to mass manufacturer
vehicle reliably and at scale
um
I mean even for Rockets I'd say it's
probably a factor of 10 harder to
design the manufacturing system for a
rocket then design the rocket and for
for cars I'd say it's maybe a hundred
times uh harder to design the
manufacturing system than to design the
vehicle itself
um
so uh that's what the freeway
I don't mean to have it in black and
white it's like it's not so long ago
they didn't even have color cameras back
then
it was 2010.
um but it was very Bleak it's like
essentially the the you know when we
acquired the the Fremont Factory which
used to be called numi uh people sort of
thought oh you've got a car factory now
if you have a car they sort of think if
you have a car factory you can just make
any any car it's like no that's like
saying you've got a box uh and that box
can have anything you want in it no only
if you make the thing in the Box
um so although we we did get the the we
at a
um get a very good deal on the The numi
Factory uh Toyota and General Motors
actually took all of the good equipment
out
um and anything that that had what that
was like so useless it wasn't even worth
the scrap was left
that so it literally looked like that
but in color
um
um and and it took an enormous amount of
effort by a very talented team to
actually turn essentially what looked
like a derelict Warehouse into a working
working car factory
yeah
so
and in fact like today the the Fremont
Factory which is an enormous building I
think it's like the second or third
biggest building in the world by
footprint is so dense it's so densely
packed with with people and robots by
this picture has like robots but there's
20 000 people that work in in the uh at
the Fremont Factory
um across four or five shifts so it's
really a massive amount of people
um and robots
so it's like those giant cybernetic
Collective
so
that that wasn't that was way harder
than making the car by far
um
and um
I mean it's worth noting like the the
last time at least in in the US last
time any car company achieved Mass
manufacturing was about a hundred years
ago
that is the last time and then Tesla
it's literally that crazy
so
[Applause]
like like the issue is definitely not
coming up with a car design it is
absolutely all about bullying the
production system
um that you want to have a good product
to build
but that's that's basically the easy
part
um then the Factory's the hard part then
then the the challenge is like okay if
we if we create a car factory where the
heck are the batteries and and electric
motors and Power Electronics going to
come from
um and and that's where we we need to
set okay we better build something
that's capable of
50 gigawatt hours at least of of cell
output which at the time when we
proposed the gigafactory I believe like
total Global output
for of silica of Lithium-ion batteries
for all purposes phones laptops
facility you know cars anything was
about 30 gigawatt hours
so we're like okay well just do the
basic math we need something that's we
need 50 gigawatt hours so
um we're about to have a real big
Factory
um
or there's no way so
um
and uh
we're going to build it in in California
but like they were to take Interiors
just to get the permits
um so we built the gig Factory in the
amount of time it would it would have
taken to get the permits in California
um that's what the gigafactory looked
like
in 2010 it was basically rocks and
bushes
okay and now this is what it looks like
now
thank you
[Applause]
yeah
so and it's only about a third complete
so the the this one complete I think
it's about four or five times the size
of the Pentagon
um so it's kind of difficult to
appreciate scale but that that although
it is it's really quite tall it's like
70 feet tall
um so uh but the volume of it is just
mind-blowing um it takes two hours just
to walk around it
so
um
you know again it's a work of a
tremendously talented team working like
crazy like tens of thousands of people
to produce this this uh this Factory
um and today it it produces uh more uh
lithium-ion than the rest of the world
combined
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now now we're also building a factory in
in China which I'm really excited about
um as you can see
it's it's the the
very impressive
very impressive
um a large puddle um so that when um
when it was there in January uh that's
that's what it looked like when we did
the groundbreaking ceremony
and this is what it looks like now three
months later
but
this is what it will look like at the
end of the year
so I think things are things are moving
fast
um and the this will actually be
um once it's complete the equivalent of
our Fremont car factory plus our Nevada
uh battery gigafactory combined
yeah so it's integrating the two which
kind of makes sense
um
so yeah so we're really excited about
this
um a great great team in China and this
is going to be really important for
making
um affordable versions of the model 3
and model Y for the for the greater
China Market
and then besides cars we have some other
things
so the solar roof and powerwall
so uh this is this is definitely going
to be the year of the solar roof and
powerwall
um the because of like uh extreme
challenges with the model 3 production
uh we have to basically
allocate all resources to model 3
production because otherwise we're going
to die
and and so so basically it's pretty
tight I have to say
um
that was a hard one uh I would say like
like 2018 was probably felt like aging
five years in one honestly it was really
intense
um
so that
I think thank you for supporting Tesla
through this difficult period thank you
[Applause]
great
it and now that now that model 3
production is going pretty well
um we're finally uh allocate engineering
attention to the solar roof as well as
the solar retrofit I'm pretty excited
about both the solar tile roof and the
solar red foot and a power wall
um like part of the reason we can also
connect parallels we we I couldn't make
enough sales so it allocate sales to the
car or to the power one was like we've
got to make the cars so then power wheel
gets sell Star basically but 2019 so we
are now going to ramp it up
and then power pack
so power pack is kind of like our
industrial strength
battery storage system and we did the uh
the biggest battery storage system in
the world in Australia
um and yeah
that was that was really super cool
um and then we're doing one that's a
roughly a gigawatt hour scale in
California
so just in Southern California right
nearby we're building a gigawatt hour
scale power pack and so expect this to
ultimately be a really critical for
transitioning the world to sustainable
energy obviously you have to have
sustainable energy production and
sustainable energy consumption so the
sustainable energy production need the
solar panels plus the battery because
the sun doesn't shine at night and then
those electric cars you know electric
vehicles in general yeah
so
but I mean the really exciting thing is
if you have with with solo solos solo
Plus Battery Plus electric vehicles we
have a fully sustainable future this is
a future you can feel really excited and
optimistic about I think it really
matters
[Applause]
and then supercharging so
um you know the the first in 2010 we had
zero superchargers so there was no you
couldn't really Drive long distances
with an electric car uh in in 2010
um
so it was like okay we better have some
high some high power charges otherwise
it's going to be extremely inconvenient
to drive long distances so
uh built into the the model S
um that was a high voltage DC bypass
directly to the pack so you can just
sort of Mainline power right right into
the pack
um and then we stick it then
nobody was building high power charges
so like okay we're better with these
high power charges because nobody's
building them and um so we went from
zero uh superchargers to building a
Global Network of superchargers
yeah
yeah so
[Applause]
it's pretty nutty each one of those each
one of those is a supercharging site
so
um supercharging Team tested an
incredible job uh building uh a Global
Network of superchargers that allow you
to travel uh to a massive section of of
the world basically anywhere in North
America almost anywhere in Europe uh
most places in China not the Gobi desert
yet but most places
um we'll cover the Gobi desert we'll get
there
and Saskatchewan I swear to God there is
I've specifically asked about the
Saskatchewan supercharger
and I'm told it is it is under
construction so
um absolutely
I've asked about it like twice it's
I'm told it's going to be completed soon
and then you will actually be able to
drive across Canada
um so yes
um
Hawaii
okay
[Music]
actually we have like some great
supporters in Kazakhstan I think we
probably
we we should have we will build
superchargers in Kazakhstan there you
hit it right here
[Applause]
uh anyway we're gonna build a lot more
Super charges
um and and we have actually a version
three of the supercharger that we just
unveiled and in fact uh yeah
[Applause]
so the superchargers actually started
out only at about 75 kilowatts and now
they're at uh with version three uh 250
kilowatts I think probably can even go a
little a little higher than that
um and so if you've got a long range
model 3 it's uh it's capable of charging
at about a thousand miles an hour or
1600 kilometers an hour yeah
so and and we uh we have one uh working
in the Bay Area and then the one here at
the design studio is also working as of
tonight
so yeah
so so we're gonna be rolling out the
version three supercharger uh throughout
the world just gradually upgrading uh
the existing sites as well as adding new
sites
um so we did we just slow down the
supercharger well out a little bit
because we wanted them to be version
three instead of version two
um but now that we have version three
running and we'll um we're going to
spool our production and so you're gonna
have like
um a radical Improvement in
supercharging uh worldwide by sometime
next year yeah
so
so in terms of where we are today I
we got obviously the S3 and the X we've
made I think 550 000 Vehicles something
like that
um the the uh 12 months from now we will
have made about a million vehicles
so
so
it's pretty wild to think that 11 years
ago today we had made literally one car
and a year from now we will have made a
million
[Music]
yeah I mean this is a this is a
testament to to the incredible Talent uh
and and effort of the people of Tesla I
was to say thank you to people Tesla you
guys are incredible
[Applause]
so yeah and formerly in terms of CO2
saved
um
in fact with the the four millionth ton
uh it just ticked over like a like an
hour ago so the four million time just
ticked over tonight yeah
so uh you know just talking about about
like you know what were the what what
were the thoughts back back then
talk to some of the comments uh let's
see uh
the internet is forever
[Laughter]
um if this is like taster it was like
like I said it was electric cars were
considered extremely impossible and
stupid uh and in various forms that you
know you're a fraud like okay you can
drive that fraud
um okay uh and then now things have
changed
[Applause]
the the goal of Tesla was literally this
is like to what degree in fact
you know when we created like okay the
fundamental historic good of Tesla what
should be measured by the degree to
which we accelerate the advance of
sustainable uh sustainable energy and
transport
um and our goal all along has been to
try to get the rest of the car industry
to uh to go electric we did a a joint
venture thing with uh with Toyota and
with Mercedes um we open sourced our
patents uh three or four years ago
um made them freely available
um and uh so it's it's extremely
rewarding to see that the the rest of
the industry is going electric this is
great great
so
and and I was just wondering like if
where will where will Tesla be in 10
years you know
Mars yeah exactly
uh we will be driving at Tesla on Mars
I think we could I think we actually
could
[Applause]
okay
Tesla will be on Mars in 10 years I
think it will I think well
so after that's an extended history or
history lesson
what about the actual
the actual reason you came okay
this a missing car
it's it starts with a y and so the why
and that's why in the middle they're not
the model y
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
come on
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the model y
[Applause]
'all
so uh like the three it will be
extremely safe so that the you may know
the mall three uh has the uh the lowest
probability of Entry of any car ever
tested by the U.S government
um the model y we expect will have a
similar result uh five stars never ever
category with the battery pack alone low
in the floor it's going to have a very
low center of gravity so this will it it
has the functionality of a of an SUV but
will it will ride like a sports car so
this thing will be really tight in
corners and we expect it will be the the
safest uh mid-size SUV in the world by
far and at Tesla we actually always
design with safety as the number one
goal
um it's it's like like people people
think okay performance sure but but
safety first
um this is actually by far the most
important thing but it's also going to
be have incredible performance so we
expect to have a three and a half second
zero to sixty
um
yeah it's pretty good
um and uh very low center of gravity so
great great uh handling uh it's testing
out at a 0.23 drag coefficient which is
extremely good for an SUV
um and in terms of range
fair amount
yeah
so we expect to have an EPA range of an
actual true usable range of 300 miles
so yeah
[Music]
yeah
from an interior standpoint it has a
panoramic glass roof and by the way
after I'm done here you guys will be
able to come up and like check out the
car so it's like
um
so it's gonna have a panoramic glass
roof it like really feels like just like
the model 3 if you're in the car it just
feels like you're you can see the sky
uh
seats seat seven 66 cubic feet
obviously autopilot since you know all
that and uh as I've said publicly we
expect to be feature complete with uh
with self-driving sometime later this
year and then as as we prove out the
safety with uh billions of miles and
kilometers uh uh we will uh
from our standpoint feel it's like safe
enough to not pay attention and then get
the regulatory approval sometime
thereafter but the cool thing is feature
complete like it'll be able to do
basically anything
um uh biting this year just with soft
just with software upgrades which is
pretty cool
so
um the the basically long-range one we
expect to be about forty seven thousand
dollars and then sometime in 2021 we'll
have the the sort of Standard Version
which will be have a 39 000 price point
so yeah
[Applause]
uh now the seven seats are optional
yeah
do you mean the liftgate
yes
okay
um
[Applause]
I mean you never know we might do better
than this but so it should be at least
that's good so uh so I think it's gonna
be very like really compelling I'm
confident that it'll be the the the of
any mid-size SUV it'll be the one you
want
um and uh
yeah I think it'll probably sell I think
we'll probably do more model wise than
sxn3 combined most likely yeah
so
so there you have the sexy presentation
so
all right
uh so thank you all for coming uh
um those of you are here and those who
are watching thank you very much for
your support over the years it's been uh
you know a hell of a ride and uh I
I love you too I love you too
we are bringing sexy back quite
literally all right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]